losing something we love or someone who
is dear to us can cause us a lot of pain
to accept the loss and overcome the pain
we often go through five stages of
grief denial anger bargaining depression
and finally
acceptance first comes denial when we
experience a loss we feel shocked and
numb and then simply deny what happened
the refusal to accept the truth
temporarily protects us from all the
negative thoughts and consequences of
the tragedy denial gives us a bit of
room to
breathe then comes anger we feel Furious
and resentful often blaming ourselves or
others for the catastrophe anger Shields
us from pain we feel less vulnerable and
More in control of the
situation then there is bargaining it is
an attempt to regain control and
negotiate the reality of the loss we try
to make promises or seek outside
solutions to somehow reverse the
irreversible when the loss sinks in
depression follows we go through
feelings of sadness and despair we
withdraw from others as we face reality
depression can help us process our grief
healing can
begin lastly there is acceptance we come
to terms with what has happened this
does not mean we forget but we find a
way to integrate the loss into our life
we may now honor the memories of those
who have departed and look ahead knowing
that after all life goes
on getting to accept acceptance however
does not mean it is
over grief is a complex emotional
response to loss particularly the loss
of someone we love or something deeply
meaningful like a job this process is
unique to each of us and is not always
linear often we cycle back revisit
stages or experience some entirely new
emotions sometimes it can feel like
we're regressing
but with the support of others and each
new day time will help heal our
wounds Elizabeth kuer Ross a
psychiatrist who supported those facing
their own death observed the five stages
in the
1960s she later wrote the most beautiful
people we have known are those who have
known defeat known suffering known
struggle known loss and have found their
way out of of the
[Music]
depths what do you think have you ever
experienced a significant loss in life
and if so did you go through these five
stages or did you take another path to
deal with it please share your thoughts
and insights in the comments
[Music]
below
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on